Welcome back everyone, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my new Marvel Wolverine
video in weapons plus breakdown.
I got a couple requests to do videos about
new Wolverine stuff happening.
The MCU, the director of the Logan movie was
even talking about some interesting Hugh Jackman
future Wolverine stuff.
The breakdown got a bunch of good news about
what's happening in the second half of the
year with all the big Marvel Disney plus series
and the movies.
So if you're new to the channel
Be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new Amazon giveaway all you have
to do to enter is be subscriber and let me
know what you want them to do with the new
version of Wolverine inside the MCU so just
go nonetheless starting with number five will
start with the good news because everybody
needs as much good news as possible right
now, Marvel revealed that all the previously
announced Avengers Disney plus series episodes
will be released this year.
That means falcon winter soldier in one division
episodes all before the end of the year.
This is also important for mutants MCU and
Wolverine stuff and I'll explain the second
to but it is good news to hear that there
will be more delays.
It was a big question about when they were
actually in a drop episodes just a couple
days ago.
The official Disney plus Twitter account was
responding to a random user about an unrelated
question into the falcon winter soldier will
drop in the fall that means sometimes starting
in September or October just because that's
when the fall starts originally was supposed
to release at the end of the summer that was
in August, so it's not a big deal.
Just delayed a couple weeks the we can handle
that.
Just happy that were getting it.
We don't have to wait till next year that
series is going to be laying a lot of track
work for the weapons plus program weapon X
and Wolverine down the road they'll explain
the second all the Wandavision episodes are
still coming out in December.
It hasn't been delayed it all, it was always
coming out in December there actually further
ahead in production on one division, then
they aren't falcon winter soldier even though
they shot falcon winter soldier first they'll
be more trailers for both of those series
later this summer.
So just stay tuned for that but number four
even better.
The big MCU Marvel Wolverine stuff recently
is mostly about Wolverine deleted scenes and
Marvel movies in the weapons plus super soldier
program that they're bringing back for storylines
in new movies and Disney plus series since
Marvel is gotten the rights to the X-Men characters back
We actually found out about a lot of original
deleted scenes from older Marvel movies that
they had planned with those X-Men characters
a while ago Kevin feige revealed that there
was a Wolverine deleted scene in the first
Captain America movie not in the way you'd
expect, but still very cool.
Originally it was supposed to happen when
Captain America was going to say Bucky in the
Hallie commandos he was going to find the red
skull had also captured a much younger version
of Wolverine in magneto this version of Wolverine
wouldn't have his adamantine skeleton yet
because he would not have gone to the weapon
X program, but he was born with his healing factor.
That's how he was able to be born in the late
1800s then fighting the American Civil War,
World War I in obviously because were talking
about Captain America deleted scenes World
War II magneto would've been a child at the
time.
So his powers would've barely manifested so
he wouldn't of been much of a threat to red skull.
Number three.
The reason why this wound up being a deleted
scene that it cut it out of the movie was
because Fox would not agree to let them use
the characters at the time because when they
were making the movie around that same time
Fox was making X-Men Wolverine origins, which
was middle era, Hugh Jackman Wolverine, but
now the Marvel controls all the characters
again is very easy for them to wrecked con
that detail back into MCU history Spider-Man
style.
This is a reference to the younger version
of Spider-Man, Peter Parker and Iron Man two
what Iron Man two was filmed Jon Favreau said
this little kid under the mask was played
by his son in real life it was just a random
kid who loved Iron man, but when Tom Holland
and Kevin feige were doing press for Spider-Man
homecoming a couple years ago during an interview
Tom Holland said wouldn't it be cool that
little kid was Peter Parker providing even
deeper connections between the Iron man and
Spider-Man characters Kevin feige like the
idea so much that he declared it can, and
even though technically it wasn't film to
be that way, so it's no different with MCU
Wolverine he's been here this whole time.
You just didn't see him because he was trying
to fly under the radar, so no one would find
out he was a mutant mutants in the MCU is
something we'll hear more about.
During marvel phase for through the one division
series in the Marvel eternals movie, but
the leading theory is that hidden amongst
us theory there've always been mutants around
the just and few in number and it managed
to fly mostly under the radar until after
the events of Avengers infinity war in Avengers
endgame in the cosmic energy released by each
of the snaps just created events that triggered
a lot of people's X genes and that's why by
the time we get to marvel phase 5 will start
to see more mutants popping up around the world.
Thanos snapped his fingers. Earth became ground zero
for a power surge
of ridiculously cosmic proportions no one's ever seen anything like it.
But number two in the short term Marvel
is bringing the weapons plus program back
on the road to eventually doing weapon X through
falcon winter soldier so weapons plus is basically
the overarching name for the super soldier
program different super soldiers through history
that the military has experimented on the
been over 15 of them including Captain America
Deadpool and Wolverine, but more recently
with weapon H which is basically a version
of the Hulk within adamantine skeleton.
So starting at the beginning there was actually
a precursor called weapon zero for project
rebirth weapon one is technically Captain
America that is project rebirth as you saw
during the first Captain America movie.
But before Captain America.
There was a soldier called Jon Steele from
World War I that verse kind in red skull experimented on.
As they were trying to create project rebirth
weapon to which is a bunch of animals that
they experimented on weapon three was a character
named Harry pizer.
There was a mutant with elastic multisensory
skin weapon for was something that would eventually
lead to the creation of man thing, weapon
five was sort of an offshoot of the symbiotic
program then try to use a symbiont to create
a super soldier later in present day they
would use that program to create agent venom
weapon six was Luke Cage weapon seven was
nuke obviously with some of those characters
during the Lou cage series whether Nate was
just a bunch of criminals and psychopaths
that they experimented on weapon nine was
actually originally supposed to be Deadpool
according to Rob liefeld Wade Wilson, but
then later Marvel change some things in it
wound up being typhoid Mary weapon 10 is opposite
weapon X Wolverine.
According to Rob liefeld, weapon 11 was
supposed to be Garrison Kane weapon 12 was Huntsman
weapon 13 was Fantomex weapon 14 were the
Stepford cuckoos we saw version of them during
Marvel's X-Men gifted series weapon 15 was
ultimatum part of this big super sentinels
program weapon 16 is actually character called
allgod a literal living religion which sounds
pretty crazy and it is the next program after
that which is called weapon infinity is project
death lock if you remember the death lot character
than weapon H more recently is the version
of the Hulk that got adamantine skeleton, but
his name in real life is Clayton Cortez.
They harvested DNA from Amadeus chose version
of the Hulk in the old man Logan version of
Wolverine then bonded the adamant him to his
skeleton and I know you're all asking about
the regular Bruce Banner version of the Holt
because technically thunderbolt Ross within
the MCU's version of weapons plus said that
banner was working on the super soldier weapons
plus program to because his gamma research
was a big part of that about activating people's
powers and he got his gamma powers.
Does that make the Hulk one of the weapons,
technically it doesn't, but you could consider
him part of the weapons plus program in then
you have the winter soldier which is sort
of like an offshoot because that all came
from the Captain America super soldier program
then if you wanted to you could also included
the winter soldiers that Hydra created using
Captain America's blood that was stolen by
winter soldier from Howard Stark during that
intro and Captain America Civil War.
This also read Guardian during the black widow
movie that were going to see later this year
because he was basically an offshoot of the
Captain America program done by the Russians
not by Hydra but by the Russians.
So number one you're all asking what is this
have to do with the MCU Marvel version of
Wolverine that they're going to debut in a
couple years and what about Hugh Jackman's
Wolverine.
This is all tied together because recently
the director of Logan did say that yes he
killed the Wolverine character in it was a
big conversation with Fox when they were making
the movie of all that was intended be a book
and for his character and will Hugh Jackman
is made it pretty clear that he's not going to
come running back to play the MCU version
of Wolverine in all the brand-new Marvel movies.
He's not completely opposed to ever doing
anything with the Logan character again the
way the director of the Logan movie talked
about it he said as long as there was a compelling
story that would probably be enough to get
them back on board for some Hugh Jackman Wolverine
stuff, but whatever form that would take just
remains to be seen because it would have to
be the best script you ever read in your entire
life.
The whole idea of the new MCU version of Wolverine
is it is, is comic book authentic as possible.
Even though the Marvel movies change a lot
of things.
They have everything they need to do an authentic
weapon X Wolverine Backstory so everybody
let me know in the comments.
How do you want them to do weapon X Wolverine
stuff in the MCU.
Obviously, it's not can happen for a long
time, but they're all laying that track work
right now will start to see that during the
falcon winter soldier episodes later this
year, which thankfully will get to watch before
the end of the year but if you have any big
requests for new Marvel X-Men or related videos
just let me know in the comments below in
And I'll name a new giveaway winner when I post my next
marvel video, everyone click here to learn
about the new MCU ghostwriter project is happening
and click here to learn about what's going
on with the Justice league Snyder cut that
teaser trailer thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe see you guys tonight!